[Music]
ah
that voice and that suit jasmine
sullivan
stunned as she sang the national anthem
sunday alongside country star eric
church at super bowl 55.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
their performance marked the first time
the song has been performed as a duet in
over a decade
ahead of their performance jasmine who
had not met eric before the super bowl
shared her hopes for their collaboration
with e.t we
definitely come from two totally
different uh yeah
everything but i'm excited i think it'll
be cool
to blend the different sounds of music
and and just show some unity
their performance received tons of
praise from viewers on social media
including country music star keith urban
who tweeted quote
issy and jasmine when's the duet coming
talk show host chairman hall also let
her followers know that jasmine sullivan
is her mvp of the night this year the r
b
singer had big shoes to fill her
performance marked the 30th anniversary
of whitney houston's iconic rendition of
the star-spangled banner at the super
bowl
which coincidentally happened in the
same city of tampa florida
during rehearsals jasmine took a unique
approach to showing her respects to the
music icon in a photo that went viral
she's seen rocking a similar sweatsuit
to what whitney wore during her
performance in 1991.
obviously nobody can do another version
of better virgin than whitney but i'm
just here to represent
for my people and go up there and sing
and bring some soul to it
and that she did
[Applause]
[Music]
and there's no doubt the performance is
giving major exposure to the
grammy-nominated artists
undeniable talent jasmine opened up to
e.t about what performing on the world's
biggest stage
means to her i can't even explain it
like this is something that i never even
imagined i would
get to in my career so it came out of
nowhere and i just feel so
so blessed to have this opportunity
and just grateful
you